[Music]
get your razors smooth-faced
[Music]
get some raises
[Music]
what's up Rambler listeners this episode
is once again sponsored by our good
friends at bevel bevel shaving system
he's got amazing razors amazing razors
and it got amazing razors in places that
go through your faces and you put the
Rays in you shave your face into place
yo I just sounded like a rap for the rap
rap for a little bit it was fun I think
it's cuz I'm wearing a hoodie on while I
do the end I usually don't do the ads
with a hoodie on but I think it changes
your vibe anyways for our Rambler
listeners go to get bail Volcom slash
Hannibal and get 10% off your first
purchase that's get bevel dot-com slash
Hannibal it's great razors this is
smooth raises its bet if you got a
garbage raise his way better than if you
got a good razor this is a great razor
so step up your razor plate and go
through you get somebody some stuff for
the holidays hahaha that's not good fake
laugh anyways get bevel calm slash
Hannibal 10% off
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
on the tram
welcome Kate Valentine are you doing
yeah
what's that chi'lan what's up Kate
Valentine thanks for doing this jump
of course thanks for having me I really
act do you're the first person that I've
booked on the show just cuz I was seeing
that she was liking a lot of the videos
in her sis I follow her her name will
pop up as one of the three people that
was like if she would like a lot of them
knows it cause you might want to do the
show yeah I'm gonna be like and
everybody said now but yeah I'm a fan
I'm a fan of it's funny yeah thank you
you work with our guy Talib Kweli to
live quietly yeah he's nice guy yeah I
happened to be in Denver did I go to was
it Denver yeah I think so that's when I
met you I think I think it was Denver
because my lips was dry not hydration
was a good answer but I happened to say
I think I stayed an extra day after a
gig in Denver and night off and I looked
up the local I got pulled up the Arts
weekly with the local arts weekly the
westward of some such something like
that and sawed it tightly about a show
okay Valens how you were open it killed
it thank you
did that altitude get to you at all you
know I really don't be noticing I didn't
notice
cuz I be in my own world well no I don't
smoke you in good shape you work out I
should work out more that altitude has
taken it is is not yeah I don't know if
it's killed some touring musicians and
artists but I guess do you drink I don't
drink
oh yeah well if you drink like you drink
two beers feels like you drag a six-pack
because without who gets to you like
that yeah I don't drink I don't smoke
and then on tour I was always I get it's
not seasick but like when they when he's
driving I've had to stay on the bunk cuz
I felt nauseous all the time so maybe
it's because I was already feeling weird
that I didn't notice
yeah no drinking no smoking on the road
as incredible discipline a lot of
secondhand smoke
that's a lot of second a secondhand
smoke came real smoke so you felt sort
of light high I mean oh you know what
I'm so used to it like I was on tour
with that was um two lip styles p and
myself and I just think that particular
date styles and make that one day out of
the tour yeah he wasn't at that one but
so being around them too you get first
hand smoke and ain't even secondhand
smoke no more first hand smoke but I'm
not actually hitting the blood yeah yeah
so okay that's that clambake we used to
do it at just the conservator we'd get
my get my car and nobody opened the
windows until this blunt is gone even
when the blood is gone we recycle the
weed mmm main service yeah you gotta
stay cheap I think stay cheap and
college is fragrant and in real life too
you got it you gotta say yes I think it
I think it says something about my own
relationship with alcohol and other
stuff that whenever I hear about
somebody saying if they don't drink or
smoke honey what are you doing all that
time do you caught up on all the shows
you read two books a week
what are you doing your stomach that's
be incredible
that's cutting out lots of diarrhea time
not on a toilet you on a toilet a normal
amount of time you're not drinking
having terrible conversations what are
you killing a time with Kay Valentine
I mean I'm usually present for the
terrible conversation I do all the same
things you guys do I just don't be under
the influence so it like it's actually
entertaining because everyone I'm around
is usually under damage so I'm just
watching I laugh do you feel like an
alien a little bit sometimes I feel like
I'm in like it's why I suppose whatever
when I went when I have night so I don't
drink and I'm out and I'm around drunk I
can't do it it's funny I laugh but I
think it I think I think it's like
anything is I'm maybe it's a muscle so
you have to work that muscle and work
the brain to be in those type of
situations in my brain when I try to put
myself in those type of situations lift
that [ __ ] yeah it's like when I'm sober
and I'm wrong drunk people I'm just like
is that me like damn I don't need I
shouldn't be drinking because I don't
want to act like that so judgmental it's
funny to me who you thought about making
a weed song anyways just cuz people
smoke weed and listen to rap but are you
- yes no you know I'm too real for it
but they don't mean the thought had
crossed my mad cuz uh
a few weeks back King Logie was here and
as the artist um you know he tours all
the time he he's from LA and they smoke
a lot of weed and so he we've been
wanting to work with each other so he
called me up and we went um the studio
and his producers was playing beats and
I'm like man where we going you know
what we don't let's gonna come to this
well we gonna member back he was like
man we should smoke about weed he was
like we should talk about we even though
you don't smoke we should write a song
about weed you like you down with that
I'm like yeah I'm down with it you know
we didn't we ended up rapping about
something totally different but I was
open to it I would've gave a different
perspective
it wouldn't be the first time a rapper
talked about something they didn't do it
it's been way other extreme examples but
I would have came from a different
perspective I wouldn't I would have
talked about my experience with the
secondhand smoke second this meal would
have been real hmm yeah or you could
have kid it came from the angle of I
sell hella weed I was I love you so I
was doing some I was doing some of my
pre pre-show research and I I was listen
to some of the songs and one song had
a particularly intense energy it was
this
[Music]
go get a couple pitches Rattata I was
the [ __ ] with I said it's okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] eat everyday be that dude seated
with somebody with access to studio time
usually you see some eyes [ __ ] you you
ain't [ __ ] and then sometimes you see
and then it ends up you said him the
link didn't you I didn't send the link
but he heard it though yeah put him in
our course is your leg in the car like
you want to hear my new [ __ ] that's why
I don't have some some some women and
music that I'm attracted to but I like
if things go weird on my own I ain't
trying to be that level of Muse oh yeah
see I write a song about your ass not
you but I would you know like that's how
I that's what makes the music so real
cuz it does come from my personal
experiences and those around me but it's
like I wouldn't say nobody's name right
but yeah you know but you treat me good
you'll get a song - hey it's everybody
out there not everybody somebody treat
you good now you in a relationship no no
I think when uh when people find out
you're a Prada intimidate it didn't say
you know I heard that a couple [ __ ]
song I'm honest guy but who it's a great
song but scary no but I have had an
instant
it was a guy we've been friends for a
long time and then we were you know
thinking about taking it up a notch
they but he did let me know that he was
he felt away about you know me traveling
with I live and you know always around
cuz I'm around a lot of males all the
time you know successful most of them so
it's like you know I think that
intimidated him but that's why the
stories that you you you had a friend
that got you backstage at tie live show
yes and then you got Ty Lee up to listen
to your music has anybody snuck
backstage of yourselves
yeah it's against Elliott do Talib
sometimes we have been 45-minute
conversations with a fan about Palestine
you know he is funny because I don't
know I just when he and his artist mole
he don't really be you know I remember
we were at a show I'm s obese and his
girl this woman had came up and she was
freestyle and so on yeah and she had
freestyle to me too but it was funny
because he was like look I can't listen
to this anymore I gotta go like that's
how it was that bad that's such an
aggressive not just given information
but to just start rapping at somebody
that's how Bone Thugs got put on did
they yeah they want they want the easy
easy dressing room and just started
going I need to sneak in for my story
there's sunglasses and braids that's
those that sneak in the easies green
room in the 90s hey you buying this
story this is the story anything ever I
don't know I don't know
I'm not buying lazy crazy was all for
the back there or was it one I don't
know I don't know all I know that that
that's the story is somehow they got the
easy well while he was doing a concert
yeah they spit her ass for him and then
he signed well as someone that really
loves stories I think there's some holes
in that one and I need some more details
because I can't just see them all
walking in they have to either be
escorted or maybe one snuck in and then
he said y'all I got a few other friends
with the same last name as me and then
maybe they got to go but you can't just
walk into from NWA and just come in with
the is eazy-e got guns and [ __ ] I don't
know what high school did you go to high
school did I go to
no no I went to Roosevelt High School
which is actually in Minnesota oh you
were high school in Minneapolis Oh
another time
yeah Minneapolis I had to leave here for
a little I'm from here but I had to
leave for a little while
yeah come back come back so you grab the
winter all four years up there yep and
then came back to Chicago did you feel
different what was Minneapolis like as
that 14 18 year old Minneapolis was
diverse you know that's the first time I
ever saw a Somalian if I'm pronouncing
it correctly yeah you know and initially
I was like oh my gosh like they all wear
the same thing they all look alike you
know my first time seeing it but I feel
like I'm a lot more I'm more
well-rounded because I was able to
reside that for right a few years but I
didn't really learn how to oh I learned
how to drive there so when I came back
here driving there and driving here was
to completely think different things
it's more aggressive here very even the
pedestrians were aggressive here and I
remember when I was driving here for the
first time and this guy came in the
middle of the street and he was just
standing
he was like hit me [ __ ] I don't got
nothing to live for anyway you know and
I was just like scared you know what I'm
saying because I learned how to drive in
Minneapolis wait what what intersection
I don't even remember it was the south
side of Chicago though I was just trying
to get some heroes so I was on my way to
Harold's chicken in that was mine yeah
so people drive here crazy did you get
into any Minneapolis hip hop into that
scene why you up there listening to
brother Ali or atmosphere any of those
folks nah not really I wasn't really
into the hip-hop scene yeah I did I used
to write poetry and I didn't perform any
poetry there but when I was there I was
able to visit a car visited a college
college at st. Catherine and they had
Maya Angelou one day and so I was able
to speak with her and meet her but that
was I was more into poetry you know I
didn't get to rap so I came back here
what was my Angelo's security detail
like was that [ __ ] tight it wasn't that
I mean no she was backstage at the
college because she had two days in a
row there I saw her speak both days and
then I spoke to some of the college
staff and you know they just they saw
this young girl who was eager to me my
Angelou so they they let me go back and
I what was surprising was a Maya Angelou
demeanor dr. Angelo's demeanor because
in school they used to always say Maya
Angelou they always said dr. Martin
Luther King so as soon as I see her I'm
just like oh my gosh my Angelou you know
expressing how much I love ya and she
was like what did you call me
and she had like a deeper voice and that
was like I was like um Maya Angelou she
was like it's dr. Angelou
okay yeah all right well dr. Angelou I'm
like need to tell every one of these
girls right I think they now probably
say it now but it was just like you know
you have to make sure you you know she
was serious about that her whole but she
ended up I asked I said can I you know
I'm a huge fan I write poetry can I read
some poetry and get some feedback she
was like nope
[Laughter]
sounds like a very plausible she was
late
yeah well you should have said hold on
dr. Angelou you still gonna get these
bars I'm okay run fast I was a bit
shocked but it didn't stop me from
accent hurt I said why not you know
[Laughter]
she was like I look around the room and
she like gestures so and she was like
you have people over there I'm holding
the conversation you have someone taking
having a photo shoot and she pointed out
a whole bunch of things that was taking
place in such a small space she said if
you were to recite your poetry to me you
wouldn't be showing any respect for me
yourself or your art and you know she
made sense and I just got quiet and she
was like but I'm gonna help you
and then she was she one of her
assistants I believe her name was Miss
Duffy she was like Miss Duffy come over
here I want you to get this young lady a
car she was like I want you to keep
going keep writing I want you to send me
two of your best poems and she was like
I'm gonna help me and she was like make
sure you put personal in the red marker
so they don't they'll know to give it
delivered straight to my homestead of my
office so no you know it was cool just
and I didn't get no picture or anything
but just to have that a lot of people
can't say they spoke with dr. Maya
Angelou me and I just that's a memory
that I'm forever cherish in the moment
obviously you play the kubu as part of
you thinking I could wish for my poems
in your ears to distraction honestly up
my honest thoughts I was kind of
thinking like two ways I was like wow
this is surreal this is amazing but I
was thinking like well she's kind of
rude I don't think feel that way anymore
but at that moment yes I was you know
cuz you have when you look up to certain
people you have these like I don't want
to say it put them on a pedestal but and
that's just not the dialogue I was
expecting from her
you know what I'm saying but I wouldn't
change anything I'm grateful for it
though you probably done your mind she's
like oh sweet yeah that's gonna give me
a home did you laugh or something yeah
she's like no grandma like figure though
right so do you uh how do you think
spending your high school years in
Minneapolis do you feel like it stun it
your foot working ability yes yes cuz we
got was up here when I was up here to
footwork yeah yes I do because I'll be
trying to footwork still and it don't
come off right doesn't know you you
really try to footwork yeah when I can
you for work I mean you look like you'd
be trash that's trying to privacy of mom
I actually tried at a party when I was I
was DJing at this spot and I started
playing play some Juke songs and and I
was getting hyped and people started a
footwork circuit and I was a little
drunk not jump out of the DJ booth in
there you know and I started in a beer a
couple moves and I can feel it my [ __ ]
didn't move now it's supposed to move
and then that the rest of the dance
wouldn't go well so I just hop back in
the DJ booth oh I seen you playing songs
latest thing yeah it was looking like oh
there's somebody come back home Thank
You Sara
I didn't even he probably would have it
if I kept going but I just got I just
started overthinking it and got out of
it
smart move yeah yeah so back got back in
the shot and you got back in the shot
what do you graduate high school you
trying to pat down my eggs and find out
hey I'm just trying I'm really just
trying to find out what artist was hot
when you graduated high school what
music was popular to be honest when I
graduated high school
what I was listening to back then was um
my mom had kind of put me on like I've
always loved hip-hop but back then in
Minnesota we was listening to Elena's
Morissette yeah we were listening to
Sarah Sarah McLaughlin yeah we were
listening to her like I went through a
period where that's what my mom was
listening to so that's what I was
listening to and uh Missy a lot of Missy
Elliott you know you know but ever since
I was like a toddler I have been
listening to hip-hop because of my mom
you know her boyfriend at the time I was
just always around it but then I went
through my alternative music phase and
then I really got back into hip-hop when
Drake I would say when Drake can't I
never knew my love for hip-hop yeah it
renewed it yeah and it made me that's
when I first found out that like that's
when I got the confidence to start
wrapping myself after hearing Drake eat
something about successful Drake there
out of so far gone Drake thank me later
Thank You Leigh yeah because I was like
wow here's somebody because also you're
24 if you guess it I'll tell you
rumba shows drink or smoke so that
automatically makes her look younger no
matter what 26 I drink is smoke and well
they don't looking at getting me but
yeah you can't do that that shouldn't
that shit'll put you years don't put
years on your face
but um yeah I heard Drake and I just
felt like you know cuz my favorite
rapper of all times is 2pi hmm but when
I heard your I'm like man he's rapping
but he's coming from a perspective that
I would come from you know I I feel like
Drake and not to say he's feminine in
any way but he's able to give you a
feminine point of view if that makes any
sense you know
just how he I guess because he was
raised by a single mom and he maybe has
a lot of female friends or interactions
but when I heard that you know cuz Drake
is my hard core but he's still a dope
he's still a super dope rapper to me you
know what I'm saying so I was like okay
if he could do it I definitely can
yeah Drake's uh I mean he would get
really he gets really specific about his
uh interactions with with some women him
like yeah oh girl Cheryl from the Waffle
House it was four o'clock right no net
Waffle House's Yelp yeah that really had
that would it was a Hooters or something
yeah and he shouted out a girl something
on my some Atlanta about yeah but he
Internet founder isn't that 1985 yeah
I'll just yeah John Steven yeah you said
her name
yeah her name yeah he's boosted some
strippers careers out for just a quick
name drop Wow
Malaya tell Malaya I'm on fire she
should work tonight deliveries up I've
got the beat I don't listen to miss me
that often anymore but I remember the
line do with the auto-tune
[Applause]
it's really fun got one long as hair
[Music]
[Music]
well you get right there k Valentine for
this you got vinyl yes this is gonna
write up this is your you ladies out
with my first album my baby album yes
yeah I know yeah yeah but there's our
debut album yeah here for a reason here
for a reason
yeah yeah I've listened I listened to a
few of these songs earlier today oh
there's some smooth [ __ ] on there you
got the BJ to Chicago kid track on there
that's real Atlanta yeah and the vinyl
the vinyl matches the dress damn yeah
doesn't that's your that sounds very
sensual song but that's not about a guy
is it no it's about Atlanta yeah it's
good song it's just like a create I
wanted to quickly create a spinner cuz I
love me Atlanta Atlanta to me is like I
would buy a spot there you know what I'm
saying just that's one of the few places
that I've been where I feel like the
unity amongst
everybody but specifically amongst black
people like it's so strong you know and
I just like the energy there so one day
I was getting ready to go to Atlanta and
while I was packing I was listening to
beats and that particularly became up
and I'm like okay Atlanta Atlanta I miss
you but I'm like I'm finna I'm from
Chicago so I'm gonna just write about
the city like so you know I'm like I'm
gonna put a spell and talk about a guy
so nice which did you record mostly in
Chicago yeah mostly in Chicago Chicago
and some in Miami some in New York but
mostly here does I mean obviously you
live here right but is there anything a
little more inspirational like do you
get I used to live in New York and now
when I go back it does the energy
everyone whoa the city kind of makes you
want to get your [ __ ] together you feel
that in other spots Miami New York do
you get night um I feel that wherever
I'm at because that's just a me period
but New York needs better food yeah
what's the food in New York maybe I'd
say me maybe I've been going to the
wrong I feel like all the travel in
Chicago still I think we got some good
food yeah I think you I think you just
had the wrong host in New York biggest
city in the world you just said you were
to the wrong fall spots again yeah
mm-hmm all right well okay I'll send you
some recommendations let me know next
time you go on a New York trip okay okay
this is a separate thing that when I was
looking at all the songs you had a song
with Vic Vic Spencer yeah yeah and
there's also a vixen they've done a song
together but because you got a
Vicks prints I feel like you got to
switch it up man like he said what his
name yeah that's too close if it was my
[ __ ] out here named Hannibal furnace or
some [ __ ] uh trainable Kurtis I was like
yo let's let's talk real quick
what about Aesop Rock and he said rocky
that's very that mean that's just no you
think ASAP rocky knew somebody had my
name
what when I first started rapping this
guy's to hit me on Twitter it's like you
ain't even got no followers you ain't
gonna do nothing in rap you weak you
this you that his name a Valentine to oh
but the thing about it is like my name
really is Kay Valentine kay is the first
initial my you know first name first and
then Valentine is my middle name right
Valentine was my father's name
my mom gave it's okay Valentine it ain't
so much it's made up mmm I took my
middle name my first first letter myself
it's like and I'm like what guy will
Kate Valentine name her name
it's a do it was a do the R&B singer nah
he was a rapper oh that's a soft ass rap
name for him for him right but yeah I
don't know where he is now like that was
like years ago yeah yeah my sweet um
check up on him I don't want to take a
photo let's say but I thought was good
once I got the domain for the website
kayvon I turn back on I'm like oh oh yes
how much time in between that weird
twitter twitter interaction with him and
getting the domain was there or did you
wait get it buddy I see you like you
probably get it right away right away
it's soon he think he gonna have my name
I got the website yeah cuz you know the
kibosh on that a real quick he was
probably drunk sending them tweets - she
was sober credit card out by the way by
go daddy.com knocked it out
[Laughter]
that's legit predict business names by
the domains and then yes and then those
people got a buy it back yeah yeah
Hannibal Burres dot-com got Hannibal
Hannibal Chau got Hannibal Buress with
two R's two misspelling yeah yeah check
Tony trimmed back
[Laughter]
what's your favorite track off of this
my favorite track oh that's a hard one
you know because I you know I'm on every
track but cuz I want every song but if I
just have to pick one okay I would say
soul-searching is featuring styles Pete
[Music]
yo it's only right to standard start
with myself first
I'm golden when I'm strolling solo don't
you for self we're gonna jam ain't too
religious you barely see me at church
attend the church Lana don't follow
[ __ ] don't be my first man that's a
rule track I love to take you to knock
out that verse soonest style sent me his
verse cuz he actually he recorded his
words first
I sent through the beat just to make
sure he liked it and he recorded his
verse Cynthia and I wrote mine like
right there on the spot yeah yeah and I
recorded it the next morning
oh so you a quick knock it out you do a
lot of takes are you up in there nope
yeah sometimes I could be a thirty take
Jake sometimes it depends on how long I
had before I go you know what I mean
because if I'm able to practice it a
couple of times before I get the studio
there not be good but right sometimes
you know or most of my takes be good but
sometimes like nah I want to say it this
way like I implement change while I'm
right there in the booth yeah you know
what what's when you're yeah when you
start doing big ass venues headlining
what sure I always ask people what is
their ideal just big money production
stage [ __ ] like just see Travis Scott he
got this big-ass weird ego that he's on
top of and he's flying across the crowd
or the Watch the Throne tour had J Kanye
opposite sides of the arena on these
huge pillars or yeezus tour you got I've
got the mountain and he got a Jesus out
there and all these dancers what type of
show you want to add you know what I
don't think I will
I haven't thought about like when I
imagine myself in that moment I think of
like um I definitely I think more of
like Beyonce and how she has she shows
like in between her songs she'll show
you film you know of her you know doing
whatever riding a horse you know I want
to do stuff like that and I definitely
want to have dances you know people
don't know that I'd be dancing and [ __ ]
so you know but nothing like super crazy
because I might captivate with that art
right you know
who's the guest that we had that said
don't want a jet packs I think that was
the Joey / that was Joey Joey Park yeah
yeah he wanted jetpacks see and I know
that stuff is also expensive oh yeah
budget right honey sometimes I'll see
somebody show that thing man they might
be breaking even on this right oh I was
watching a family video and Michi was in
there you know Michi oh oh yeah yeah
yes that's my guess you've been to Michi
shells before I have um I performed
actually he was doing a like a open mic
night comedy night and I performed
that's how I yeah yeah it was just a
funny funny I was watching the video is
it that meeting and then he got a
close-up is like it is meet see he was
in the background first I didn't expect
to see meet you in a background video is
this this is this relaxing it's
different what do you do to relax and
meditate you know I need some medicine I
heard meditation is really good I got a
friend I swear by I can't I don't know
I'll try every time I do it I start
thinking about food or you know
something will come in and black out the
holidays you practice your meditate
diets that's part of it yeah
is that is the focus on your breathing
and to block out all of that yeah
you never drank or smoked yeah I have I
just I've tried it I just the thing
about it it's not like I'm on some
healthy well I do want a healthy
lifestyle but I just don't like the way
it tastes
I would much rather have a glass of
kool-aid
you know I'd be seeing people getting
wasted I'm like I'm like that [ __ ] is
nasty though do you
it's not sweet it's not it doesn't taste
good for me
when you uh these days when you drink
kool-aid do you do it from scratch with
the mix and a sugar in a pitcher do you
you having like a free make kool-aid
I haven't had kool-aid in a minute but
if I do get cool eh it's gonna be from
scratch I they have pre-made cooler sure
yeah I'm out juice regular juice it's
from a story about kool-aid like
kool-aid they got that little you know
the juice bottles there there's stuff in
a six-pack for the kids
Oh with the little twisty thing [ __ ]
with that fake your kool-aid probably
made out of that glucose [ __ ] anyway
make the good kool-aid with the cane
sugar mmm I haven't had kool-aid in a
while man I miss it I miss it you know
what you miss it and I smoked before I
want to smoke again like you do want to
smoke so what's stopping you smoking I'm
just playing no cuz my experience my
price is very smoky I don't know like
[Music]
you know uh out and I wanted to tweak I
wanted to feel what everybody else
claimed they feel but I didn't feel
anything my throat was just burning oh
you know what sometimes like the first
two three times I smoked weed didn't
work for me huh one of my boys
Tamura and now Lahey like literally it
took him like over ten times together
and we were I was making him rip bongs
big-ass pipes making him smoke blunts to
the dome and I'm like you're getting
high
like man maybe maybe this just doesn't
work for you finally one day work
sometimes it takes people a couple of
times and you might burn your throat I
think you should need to give it a
couple more tries are you thinking ask
to smoke give it a couple of tries you
guys good employees I mean it's not
gonna ruin your life
right no I know yep what do you follow a
monster siblings I am
middle child
[Music]
any other musicians are rappers amongst
siblings
no not rappers my um one of my sisters
she can sing but you know she's not at
this moment
that's not something she's pursuing she
sings in a church
[Music]
what's he know big enough but she wants
out of things done at the crab dish I'm
just trying to get him she doesn't do it
that's yeah it's not something like
she's not pursuing a career in music but
she can sit at the cream commercial come
on yes you need to fire one of these
because you ain't gotta do [ __ ] with
this Kate hey Alan time what up you got
New Guinea TV placements and affording
your songs yet no not yet if you did get
a placement what what show what you
wanted to pop up all and secure and
secure that's why I'm gonna say that's
yeah insecure is becoming a good spot
for music yes [ __ ] this uh on the nose
yes baby playing some [ __ ] like she be
looking for a battery for a vibrator and
there'll be a sign can't find a battery
for my Bob not that particulars up but
it's been other situations in the show
where the song that's fitted perfectly
yeah I could see uh what was that
[ __ ] [ __ ] was it other [ __ ]
yeah yeah that could be that that would
fit in there actually that witness some
other stuff but with the tone of that
show that that song could be on there
I'm gonna get some music on that watch
yeah mmm okay all right that's what's up
Lisa you watch it insecure not haven't
gone through it yeah people it's intense
the show isn't intense but the I like
watching the the internet chatter after
each episode you follow it I mean you
watch this up with you look at it
afterwards people are the tweets the
tweets the articles like I haven't seen
that many shows that many black shows
written about like that like as far as a
bunch of different outlets review it and
they have that takes on in Laurens and
people take given to these characters a
lot man where they the girl did grow the
place Tasha
Dominique she gets she gets hate mail
about her character
well yes a [ __ ] this [ __ ] ain't
he's not real yeah people get connected
I saw that it was an article about yeah
that's great
what people write me sometimes why don't
you break up with Alana on broad city
why'd you break up with her I'm a [ __ ]
cuz Alana wrote that [ __ ] like that is
her show
why were you a dachshund in a secret
life of pets they like that with power -
yeah probably got married in real life
they was under his wind pick talking
about some book ghost is still in jail
you know really I guess that's when you
know you've done a good job with a show
people need to escape when was the last
time you were legit furious man furious
she wrote that song that was a couple
years recently hey who pissed me off
recently that you did you'd do that
while you tell them and being mad at
yourself don't count right uh sure cuz
that is the thing you can control the
most except if you mad about yourself in
a you know oh let me just change that
well you mad about yourself about you
know how you do we ain't gonna go into
all that but I would say
[Music]
[Music]
I've been mad at myself on I fear it's
the last time I was truly truly
SuperDuper angry was that this one they
got that I used to mess with yeah I am
been that mad in a minute and I got to
it I got hit by a drunk driver back when
I was working on this album you wouldn't
call car I was in a car and I was
actually on my way now I had been known
as that for some years we were friends
and then we started dating he had been
trying to get with me for a minute and
I've really played the long game what's
that
that's what lots of dates lots of days
no not even paid start being buddies
oh you know museum-going yeah just as a
group of five the whole time the whole
tax plan oh yes and so I'm on my way to
go see you we just gonna go out to eat
yeah I just got back in town
and I always pray say a prayer before I
get in the car like a travel emergency
prayer so this particular day I rushed
it I rushed my prayer cuz I was trying
to listen to some new music and so I get
in the car I'm getting on 94 westbound
and it's a Sunday evening ain't nobody
out there so I'm just cruising in a far
left lane Express and this dude just hit
me out of nowhere he was going to over
100 miles per hour
oh the car yeah I spent the spun around
twice hit the concrete medium flipped
over twice
land it upside down in the exit ramp the
43rd Street exit ramp [ __ ] I'm gonna
show you a pigeon all right and then um
and so he came to the scene
can I see him again after that and so
like maybe three or four months later I
just happened to see him out but like he
kind of low-key like like I don't want
to deal with this drum room abandon me
like I know he had a lot going on but I
just like I was like damn like you know
I don't know if he thought I was gonna
be crippled or what of it anyway it's
over but he literally yeah long game -
yeah I was like you piece of [ __ ] so I
was I was hurt I was angry and I you
know he was every name in the book but
you know I got over it
he finally apologized oh [ __ ] is that I
could see it was the end of 2015
okay a couple years ago yep and it was
so crazy I'm trying to find the car cuz
if you see the car like that's why in
everybody because they rushed me to
Northwestern and all the docs was like
you're so lucky people don't live
through this and buys everybody and I'm
just like yeah man you were mad at
yourself you're mad at yourself for just
a separate thing yeah that's yeah that
they flip the car over like flip my car
I know yeah yeah you know that doesn't
look like you're supposed to survive
that right so know what I was saying
I've been mad at myself but I was the
last time I was super furious like with
somebody like when it's a bash they face
then I was with him yeah yeah he just
that's not cool yeah
what was your recovery time it was quick
it was like um I would say I felt myself
physically in like a month
three weeks to a month I was in the
studio the next week but I wouldn't let
you know I wouldn't taking no pictures I
wasn't on instagram cuz you know that
picture that you saw that's after they
cleaned me up but it get worse before it
get better so I ended up it was swelling
my blood vessels had pops in my eyes was
red and it was just and I had deep
gashes in my nose and it was it was the
nose open no broken no permanent damage
no broken bones crazy yep yes great
shows all bruises and gadgets no broken
bones yeah you know what else was crazy
y'all know how y'all watch them shows
them Hospital shows and they be cutting
people close up yeah they cut up my
clothes they cut my drawers off you know
thank God I had just got a wax they cut
they took my socks off I mean completely
as just naked and I had doctors all
around you know what I mean so even
though I was had just experienced I'm so
sure Matic I was sitting there like damn
I'm naked they looking at my body and
they cut my shirt I had a shirt on that
I really liked and I was thinking like
thought they couldn't my shirt did uh
you said you were in a studio week
afterwards did your was your voice
different at all no my voice was fine
mm-hmm type of a Kanye voice he sounded
yeah yeah he had the whole jaw thing
like no my stuff was just I had it I
didn't know what when it first happened
but like when I landed upside down and
realized that I was still alive it's
like because it was a whole bunch of it
was a lot of blood coming out of my
mouth I'm upside down all I was able to
move was my leg
and somehow I got out of my seatbelt and
so I started trying to kick the windows
because it was smoke everywhere and I
wasn't strong enough to break the
windows and so I started talking to
myself I'm like okay you're about to die
it was like I was but I felt calm like I
didn't panic or anything and I was
picturing I'm like damn I'm off and had
to plan my funeral and then I got tired
so I just closed my eyes like [ __ ] it
this is it this is how I'm gonna in yeah
next thing I know complete strangers
pulled me from out of the car and that's
how I made it but I said that to say I
had when all that I realized later that
all that blood I was coming out because
I did a huge hole in my mouth but it
didn't affect how I sounded or spoke or
anything so I was I was good did they
get the driver the other driver that
Buzzard was out there cuz his car got
messed up too
and so I didn't know at the time when
they pulled me from under the car
I couldn't see out of one eye but the I
was able to see out my left eye and in
my peripheral vision I was able to see
another car that was totaled and so I'm
already crying I'm like oh my gosh
it's the person that hit me is he alive
is he dead it's you know I didn't know
what was going on and it was a crowd of
people around me and it's one particular
dude was in front of me and he just was
staring he wasn't saying that everybody
else was like oh my gosh no you know
trying to pat me with paper towels all
that he and I later found out that's
been [ __ ] who hit me no he was just
standing there just looking at me like
and so um and he was lying to the police
I found out once they put me in the
ambulance he was up acting like a
witness telling people not he he
couldn't deny that he was the white
because it was his car but he said that
it was somebody else that hit him and
hit me and they kept going like he was
making up dumbass lies and I was just
thankful that it was other people there
you know who was able to you know give
account of what have really taken place
and they made him do to walk the line he
[ __ ] up then people was taking
pictures of them and getting them on
video he was cursing him out like don't
put me on video and he was just crazy so
they took him to jail that night I don't
know what happened to him afterwards
I didn't take him to court or nothing he
was driving something he didn't he
didn't have a license he was driving his
sister car
it wasn't the insurance then cover him
and everybody was like oh you could take
him to court you can do this and then
but I was so I was dealing with
post-traumatic stress disorder and I was
I was dealing with that but I was
thankful being alive I was just too
consumed mentally to even try to I'm
like running out of money yeah that's a
traumatic experience yeah I'm glad you
made it to that meet sue thanks I was
supposed to be here yeah yeah that's why
I made my album here for a reason
well thank you Kay Valentine for joining
us of course thank you Kay thank you for
having me you want to make a silly song
on our way out
yeah it's called go buy my album this
next song was called come on I have for
reason yeah last a balance and at the
very least streaming fun buying us
before
[Music]
Oh Joe you know you sound that's how you
know your
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]